if you had the opportunity to sort of in
the fall semester to have a chance to
talk to the incoming freshman students
at NYU what kind of things would you
tell them huh that's it I think it's
usually like something along the lines
of like you want to try to like try as
many things as possible and like kind of
state route or your own voice even
though it's hard because you get a lot
of feedback and people telling you to
know how to do things so I think it's
like trying to sort of maintain your own
voice and not being too like sensitive
to criticism I guess that doesn't sound
so inspiring I think just like yeah I
mean is there anything else that you
wish someone had said to you at that
time when you were just getting started
I guess um not that I can think of maybe
to not take it so seriously in the sense
that you always think every short film
you think is like the end-all be-all and
you're gonna like die if it's not
amazing so maybe to kind of realize it's
all a process and like everything is
like you know you're always like growing
and learning and it's all an adventure
like this is like a new adventure and
I'm done with school but I still feel
like I'm learning a ton so I think to
not like want everything to be totally
perfect and like yeah the absolute ends
I'll you know or something